- YES!
- HOLY COW!
THAT KID IS A JOCK!
LOVE TO SEE WHAT HE COULD
DO IN THE POOL.
I BET HE'S GOT GREAT WALTZ.
- YEAH.
ALL THESE KIDS,
THEY'RE JUST CHILDREN OUT THERE.
A LOT OF THEM PROBABLY
HAVEN'T EVEN SPROUTED PUBES.
PUT ME IN--
I'M A REAL MAN.
I'VE GOT A VERY DENSE BUSH.
- MAN, LOOK AT THAT VISOR.
THAT THING'S RAD-ASS.
HE LOOKS LIKE
COBRA COMMANDER.
- HIS TOUCHDOWN DANCE
IS A LITTLE WEAK.
WHAT I WOULD DO, IF I EVER
ACTUALLY PLAYED FOOTBALL,
IS I'D DO THE DANCE
BEFORE THE PLAY EVEN STARTED.
LET 'EM KNOW WHAT'S UP.
JUST A LITTLE...
- RIGHT.
- OH.
- YEAH.
VERY FUN DANCE.
- TIMBERLAKE.
- I LIKE IT.
UM, IT'S KIND OF STUPID
TO DO IT BEFORE THE PLAY,
'CAUSE THEN THE OPPONENT KNOWS
THAT YOU'RE GONNA GET THE BALL.
- I BET YOU $100 I WOULD
STILL BE ABLE TO SCORE.
- I DON'T BET, SO...
- I BET YOU DO.
- I BET I--
NICE TRY.
- YEAH, I GOT YOU, DUDE.
- I USED TO BE A MAJOR PLAYER
IN THE GAMBLING WORLD,
ALL RIGHT?
- MM.
- I LOST EVERYTHING.
- HMM.
- INCLUDING MY MIND.
HAVEN'T GAMBLED SINCE.
- NO, I REMEMBER THAT.
YOU LOST, LIKE, 80 BUCKS.
- IT WAS MONEY YOUR GRANDMA
GAVE YOU FOR YOUR BIRTHDAY.
- NO, BUT SHE HAD TO CANCEL
HER SUBSCRIPTION FROM CABLE
FOR A MONTH.
SOMETIMES,
WHEN YOU'RE A GRANDMA,
A MONTH'S ALL YOU GOT.